Israel's new coalition government a deal
between Benjamin Netanyahu and Benny
Ganz means the possibility it will annex
parts of the West Bank is now much more
likely I now give the floor to mr.
Nicolai in a virtual session of the UN
Security Council the man in charge of
Middle East peace efforts for the United
Nations said that would be a disastrous
step for peace in the region mr.
president
the dangerous prospect of annexation by
Israel parts of the occupied West Bank
is a growing threat if such a move were
implemented it would constitute a
serious violation of international law
deal a devastating blow to the two-state
solution close the door to renewal of
negotiations and threaten efforts to
advance regional peace the Palestinian
ambassador Riyad Mansour made it clear
it was time for the International
Conference on the Middle East the
international community must repudiate
and demand a halt to all annexation
measures do not fall prey to the pretext
crafted by Israeli officials now the
excuse of the pandemic to divert
attention from these crimes his Israeli
counterpart Danny Danon said while his
country had been helping Palestinians
during the kovat 19 outbreak the
response had been what he described as
hate an anti-semitic incitement one
Security Council member the ambassador
of Indonesia told Al Jazeera in an
interview that Israel shouldn't be
contemplating illegal action at any time
but especially not during a pandemic it
becomes a double jeopardy
meaning the issue of occupation and
there's also an issue of coffee pandemic
so I think the international community
has to ensure that there are all the
necessary assistance the necessary
humanitarian assistance and also to
ensure also that the occupying power
complies with the many UN resolution
it's pretty clear among the Security
Council the u.s. is the only country
that would not object to Israel annexing
part of
the West Bank however can the other
members of the Security Council take any
action to stop it well the u.s. is a
permanent member and almost certainly it
would block any resolution using its
veto power James BAE's al Jazeera of the
United Nations